I got another big idea let's get AMC to put
a theater in Decentraland!
What if they not only got into online in a
big way but still kept the spirit of physically
going to the theaters and hanging out with
friends.
They can sell tickets that you can buy using
Mana.
Users would be able to walk to a pizza kiosk
and order a pizza and then go to theater and
hangout with their friends and watch a movie
together all without leaving their house and
the game!
Edit: It's happening someone built a theater
yo AMC where you at you don't want to miss
this opportunity
[high intensity music]
Man when I walked in it blew my mind something
was playing I watched it for at least 5 minuets
sound and video was clear as fuck
Checked it out and it blew me away.
This is absolutely sick!
Who owns it?
This will be awesome once VR is integrated
and you can do screen sharing with a group
of friends so it’ll be like watching the
movie together.
I could even see decentraland movie gift cards
being sold at the super market in the area
where all those gift cards are located.
That’d be so cool
I wish could take all my bitcoin and live
inside this world
Dope asf!
Clap clap clap clap clap clap thumbs up ok
high five one hundred one hundred
What you’re looking at is Decentraland.
Conceived by Argentine developers Esteban
Ordano and Ari Meilich as a virtual reality
world for unconstrained markets and presently
advertising itself as a “decentralized metaverse
owned by its users.”
In the pitch version Decentraland is a true
virtual space, a whole new parallel world
that you access via virtual reality, a world
where you can shop, buy things, invest, purchase
goods, and go to stores unconstrained by the
laws that govern the place where your physical
body eats and sleeps, a product so promising
that it commands a valuation in the billions
of dollars.
In practice, it’s just a bad video game
made up of smaller, worse video games, wrapped
in a real-estate scheme cosplaying as the
Matrix.
Most of what Decentraland does, and what it
fails to do, are things that would be considered
forgivable or quaint in a Kickstarter MMO
that had clearly bitten off more than the
creators could ever chew, but given that this
is a project founded on cryptocurrency all
of those foibles are laced with the language
of finance and landlordism.
Strolling down Decentraland’s spacious boulevards
at 5 frames per second rewards the user with
a seemingly endless parade of virtual billboards
brightly proclaiming that the space you see
is all available to rent.
This is because of a pretty basic chain of
incentives that are laid bare by Decentraland’s
history.
While the nominally-playable game launched
in February 2020 the actual launch was in
2017 broken into two parts: first an initial
coin offering in August where their MANA token
sale raised approximately $24 million dollars
denominated in crypto coins, and second with
the “terraforming event” where parcels
of land, denominated in LAND tokens, were
auctioned off for an additional $28 million
in crypto, predominantly bought by guys like
this.
“I’m not selling until it’s worth at
least ten million”
This being crypto the obsession with scarcity
is so pervasive that it’s almost a waste
of time to even mention it but the LAND tokens
were limited to 90,000, which, of course,
centered a lot of the discussion of Decentraland
around the hypothetical value of the virtual
plots of land in the event that Decentraland
won the future and became the Manhattan of
the metaverse, the go-to destination for virtual
life.
The initial buyers' plans for the land overwhelmingly
veered towards pitching cryptocurrency or
financial services or just sitting on the
land with the intent of renting it out later.
This is all baked-in, Decentraland’s initial
pitch hinges on it.
“What if you could own the virtual world?
Create, develop, and trade without limits.
Make genuine connections, and earn real money.
Decentraland.
A fully immersive platform powered by the
blockchain.
Buy land.
Design your experience.
And transform he way that people see the world.
Purchase the first ever virtual real estate.
Get started today.”
Now, there’s a lot of ground that needs
to be covered, and a not insubstantial amount
of theory that I would like to get out there,
but I suspect the main thing you might be
here for is failure, so just to whet your
appetite here is a list of things you can
expect to see as we talk about Decentraland,
what it is, and what it isn’t.
[Disco Music]
Decentraland Records presents the only collection
of failure you’ll ever need!
Bad graphics
Poor performance
Dead mall vibes
Missing geometry
Weed leaves
Loading boxes
And so much more
But before we can get into all that we’ve
gotta talk about the metaverse.
In the past two years you have likely been
inundated with attempts to explain and define
the metaverse and yet, despite the numerous,
numerous attempts you probably feel no closer
to having an actual, workable definition in
your head, one that maps to something you
can visualize actually integrating with your
life.
There are a lot of definitions out there,
most of them are incredibly flimsy, many of
them are outright insane, very few agree on
anything other than the broad strokes, and
almost all of them fall back on gesturing
towards Ready Player One and going “you
know, that thing, it’ll be like that.”
In the mainstream, the metaverse has been
somewhat hijacked by the crypto and web3 crowd.
An interesting element to that is that while
they are extremely aggressively pushing the
word “metaverse” out into the public consciousness,
they are late-arriving parasites, they will
typically nod their heads at any metaverse
vision before throwing it back at you with
their crypto junk grafted onto it.
They don’t care about the form or content
of the metaverse, but both crypto and the
metaverse require spontaneous mass adoption
to make sense, so the two are somewhat simpatico
in that regard.
In sharp contrast we have the writing of Ryan
Bolger.
A theologian, Bolger’s vision of the Metaverse
is that of a reified space that sits on top
of the real world, a 1 to 1 digital clone.
You can leave a digital letter for someone
on a park bench, and they need to go to that
same bench to find it.
A clone so accurate that self-driving cars
will navigate not via sensors that monitor
the world around them, but by referencing
the current position of things in the metaverse
- the most jacked version of Google Maps you
can imagine.
For Bolger, traditional websites and apps
are just a stop gap to the ultimate aim, which
should be to astrally project via VR into
a McDonalds, where a cashier will then see
you through AR glasses and take your order
as if you were in the space.
The goal of this degree of reification was
to create a space so ‘real’ and legitimate,
that it could be said that the metaverse could
be capable of containing divinity - a church
in the metaverse can be sacred independent
of the context of human interaction because
it’s not just software, it’s a place.
Digital fashion and other “phygital” industries
also want to break down the barrier between
physical and digital, but for very different
reasons.
They look at the market for cosmetics in live
service video games and crave translating
that business model to reality.
Rather than building a reified virtual world,
digital fashion is much more interested in
the augmented reality side of things, they
want AR glasses that are so universal and
so seamless that we all dress in mo-cap suits
and composite the new Gucci over it using
an advanced spin on Tiktok’s hat filter.
In this definition the metaverse isn’t another
place, conceptual or otherwise, it’s just
a name for the digital skin that gets laid
over the world when viewed through compatible
devices.
We strongly believe that the amount of clothing
produced today is way greater than humanity
needs.
But don’t shop less, shop digital fashion.
Don’t shop less.
Don’t, don’t you, don’t you dare, don’t
you [static] dare shop less, don’t you
There are numerous problems here, which boil
down to the fact that all of these have equal
claim to the word “metaverse.”
If you comb through dozens and dozens of definitions
of the metaverse you can assemble a web of
broad attributes where some are generally
agreed upon while others border on being mutually
exclusive.
It’s a vague, largely incoherent cloud of
ideas that’s malleable enough that basically
anything can be called part of the metaverse,
a proto-metaverse, or a semi-metaverse.
Decentraland is the metaverse, TheSandbox
is the metaverse, Horizon Worlds is the metaverse,
Roblox is the metaverse, Fortnite is the metaverse,
Minecraft is the metaverse.
The Lindt Experience is the metaverse.
“I look at my fourteen year old and she
has spent the last year and a half of her
life living in a metaverse.
She doesn’t even know that word, right,
but her school is on Zoom, she hangs out with
her friends online in one form or another,
and actually in a whole bunch of different
forms, right.
In Instagram, in TikTok, in iMessage, in,
in Fortnite, in Animal Crossing, in, uh, you
know all of these different, you know, metaverses,
right”
“Some leaders within the virtual worlds
space, such as Tim Sweeney, believe that eventually,
every company will need to operate their own
virtual worlds, both as standalone planets
and as part of leading virtual world platforms
such as Fortnite and Minecraft.
As Sweeney has put it, “just as every company
a few decades ago created a webpage, and then
at some point every company created a Facebook
page.”
Of course this flexibility that allows for
anything good and popular to be part of or
a natural, inevitable precursor to the True
Metaverse simultaneously provides the flexibility
to dismiss any failure as a failing of that
pure vision rather than a failure of the underlying
ideas themselves.
The metaverse cannot fail, you can only fail
to make the metaverse.
There’s no consensus definition because
the Metaverse isn’t real, it’s not an
actual thing that anyone’s really building,
it’s a rhetorical device that allows the
writer to gesture at the future and pontificate
on what ought to be.
Definitions of the metaverse are, thusly,
principally rooted in the writer’s present
political and social values.
When you understand that the metaverse isn’t
a distinct invention or construct but merely
a rhetorical proxy for The Future of Technology
then all of this becomes a lot easier to deal
with.
The reason it’s all so messy is because
of the aforementioned gesturing towards fiction
and because a lot of the people writing effluent
prose about how the future is here today in
the form of blockchain-based social spaces
are, for the most part, salesmen.
That’s not to say that they don’t believe
the Metaverse could or should exist, just
that most have not considered if it would
actually be any good.
That part they take as a given, because it’s
always super cool in stories, so why even
bother considering that the end result might
be boring, inconvenient, and disappointing?
Now, science fiction and actual science have
a long and storied history.
It’s fun to point to all the devices that
exist today that were first sketched out by
a fiction writer decades earlier, but there’s
also a massive survivorship bias there.
Sure, some speculations become real, either
because the author rooted their speculation
in cutting edge science or because fans of
the work tried extremely hard to make it a
reality, but even more get discarded as silly,
useless, impractical, deadly, or physically
impossible.
This might come as a shock, but when a writer
sits down to compose fiction, the thing that
they write doesn’t need to actually work.
They’re not real inventions, they’re narrative
devices, and at a certain point no amount
of cool factor can make up for the limitations
of physical space.
Star Trek’s holodeck is an insanely cool
idea, and dear god do I wish it were real.
But it can’t exist, not as depicted, because
it’s not an invention, it’s a collection
of camera tricks and special effects.
At the end of the day the holodeck’s limitations,
and lack thereof, are dictated by narrative
necessity.
So when Neal Stephenson writes about The Metaverse
in Snow Crash in 1992 it is an invention composed
of a mix of speculation about the future of
existing hardware, trends in how people interact
via virtual spaces, and an overwhelmingly
cartoonish dose of Rule of Cool.
Stephenson’s Metaverse is a massive, three-dimensional
contiguous space because it’s evocative
and interesting, it provides a colourful backdrop
for the story’s gonzo plot about a high
stakes pizza delivery swordmaster employed
by the mafia and a computer virus that can
cause brain damage.
Snow Crash is prescient in degrees about some
of the ways in which we would engage with
technology, but overwhelmingly that prescience
applies to the internet as it currently exists.
We have virtual live events, virtual sports,
virtual town squares, virtual club houses,
and even virtual strip clubs where you can
hang out in chat with five hundred strangers
and watch someone just absolutely [static].
Really the only things that are missing are
either aesthetic, like the giant contiguous
three dimensional representation of the internet
where you can walk from one webpage to the
next, or maybe not even physically possible
at all, like the Snow Crash virus itself.
So this then creates a bit of a trap for a
lot of the salesmen writing about the inevitability
of the metaverse where they have to cling
to those aesthetic details as non-negotiable
because otherwise they’re just talking about
the internet.
As Matthew Ball writes in his 2022 book The
Metaverse and How It Will Change Everything
“Although virtual worlds come in many dimensions,
“3D” is a critical specification for the
Metaverse.
Without 3D, we might as well be describing
the current internet.
Message boards, chat services, website builders,
image platforms, and interconnected networks
of content have been around and popular for
decades, after all.”
Which brings us to virtual reality.
VR is pretty cool tech, I really like it.
It’s also pretty limited, or more specifically
the tech runs up against a pretty big barrier
which is the human body.
The inner ear really doesn’t like moving
without actually moving, which means that
every VR application is a series of compromises
between the immersive potential of VR and
what the body will tolerate.
No!
Oh god!
Oh!
Because Stephenson’s metaverse is a plot
device, effectively an alternate dimension,
the characters are able to navigate the space
however Stephenson wants them to.
And because it’s narratively interesting,
when the characters want to get from one part
of the metaverse to another they need to traverse
the distance between those two points.
Ball, for his part, concedes that users of
the inevitable metaverse would likely find
this to be too inconvenient and prefer to
teleport from location to location.
The reality is even more restrictive.
The compromise is that overwhelmingly virtual
reality experiences are largely static experiences,
with freeform movement around a small footprint,
with the user teleporting from spot to spot
even within the same virtual room.
It’s a compromise that VR enthusiasts are
willing to accept because the alternative
is a one-way trip to the floor as your cochlea
decides that being upright is no longer an
option.
The end result, the actuality of virtual reality,
is that it’s an incredibly potent tool for
an unfortunately limited number of applications.
This creates a very sharp contrast between
the metaverse that’s talked about by pundits
and the reality of VR that developers and
enthusiasts have been mapping for over a decade,
with pundits continuing to insist that a vast,
contiguous space representing the internet
is not only a desirable way to interact with
those functionalities, but indeed a preferential
way.
How this manifests is a metaverse that exists
overwhelmingly in the form of blog posts about
the inevitability of its existence, with anything
tangentially related to virtual reality being
encircled as part of the metaverse, along
with a whole lot of stuff hardly related at
all.
Of particular fascination is the way that
this is all talk and no product.
Lindt USA, manufacturers of terrible chocolate
truffles, launched their metaverse store in
November 2022 and just have a look at the
language used to describe it.
Lindt USA Launches Its First-Ever 3D Virtual
Store with ByondXR and Makes Shopping for
Premium Chocolate a Truly Innovative Experience
In a beautifully decorated, fully 3D and highly
photorealistic environment, the store welcomes
visitors with an engaging introduction by
one of Lindt’s famous master chocolatiers,
Ann Czaja.
Best of all, the immersive store is totally
comprehensible:
“We at Lindt USA are thrilled to offer customers
this state-of-the-art experience just in time
for the holidays.
While there is no experience like walking
into one of our beautiful Lindt stores in
person, our online store is no different.
We’re excited to show it off.”
This is all pretty routine corporate fluff,
though the surprising, and telling thing is
that it’s just words, there’s few, if
any, images included.
And there’s a reason why: the whole of it
is elevated to transcendental when you see
the actual thing that they’re describing,
a laggy, hideous, cheap faux-3D website that
would probably be a camp hit if it were pitched
instead as a throwback to FMV video games
from the 90s.
“Want some Rye?
Of course ya do!”
The vast majority of these so-called metaverse
offerings are virtual spaces only insofar
as they are painted to resemble a store.
We already tried this 25 years ago, and discarded
it because it turns out the human brain can
shop from a list of items or a grid of photos
far better than it can from an imagemap photo
of a display case.
Examples like this betray not only the ignorance
of history on the part of the people pushing
it, but also a profound incompetence on the
part of the people building it.
Rather than being a “cutting-edge virtual
shopping experience” the Lindt store is
so bad, so embarrassing, that it would be
more respectable to learn that ByondXR is
an outright scam, shaking down gullible corporations
afraid of being “out of touch” with the
future or missing the boat on the next big
thing, rather than true believers trying their
hardest.
The fact that Patrick Diggelmann, vice president
of sales and e-commerce for Lindt USA, looked
at this final product and didn’t immediately
scrap it, bury it, and demand the company’s
money back is just a nice, tight encapsulation
of how much metaverse participation is being
driven by irrational, uninformed FOMO.
And this brings us back to Decentraland.
All these definitions are pretty bad for Decentraland.
It clearly wants to be the Metaverse, it calls
itself that, but because they, like Lindt,
have made the mistake of actually trying to
make something, it's possible to evaluate
whether or not they’ve succeeded.
They have activated the trap card of falsifiability.
VR was dropped from Decentraland’s core
feature set somewhere in 2018 or 2019, and
has all but officially been relegated to a
community produced mod, which just means that
it’s difficult to get working in the first
place, and when you do nothing is optimized
for VR, either in terms of technical performance
or user experience.
The results are dizzying even without a headset
on.
Hnnng, okay so the app’s just straight up
broken now.
Cool.
For many definitions of the metaverse, like
Ball, this already makes DCL a complete non-starter:
virtual reality, or at the very least augmented
reality, is a non-negotiable feature.
This, however, in my evaluation is just a
case of No True Metaverse.
Decentraland is embarrassing, which makes
it inconvenient, which means there’s a lot
of incentive to discredit it as a claim to
the idea of the metaverse, to insist that
its failures are meaningless, that there’s
nothing to learn from them about the viability
of the underlying ideas.
But the knife that says all these definitions
are the metaverse cuts both ways.
If the concept is so broad as to be little
more than a vague gesture at the future, if
successful and popular things like Minecraft
and Roblox and Fortnite get to be the nascent
metaverse, then this does too.
And if this is the future, then the future
is a dead mall.
It is difficult to fully encapsulate the sheer
contradiction between Decentraland as it exists
in the minds of its supporters and the actual
product that you can interact with, but in
this endeavor we shall strive.
Maybe we spent our best shot early by opening
with Redditors praising a theater with non-functional
doors and a photo of a real concession stand
in place of any actual modeling, but it’s
probably best to let you know what you’re
in for.
That post that we ran earlier, by the by,
is the most popular post of all time on the
Decentraland subreddit.
The fact that it’s a crossover event with
Reddit’s memestock fanatics, right down
to being disproportionately laden with Reddit
awards as they tend to do, has a poetry to
it that I couldn’t script.
Name a more iconic duo than bad products and
serial bagholders: you can’t do it.
The pizza kiosk they rave about, where you
could, in theory, order Domino’s via the
metaverse and pay in ETH or MANA is long gone,
all that remains is an empty plot devoid of
even the world’s procedurally generated
shrubbery.
The details are thin, but from what’s available
it’s apparent that Domino’s wasn’t officially
involved in any capacity, which would indicate
that the builder had really just created a
middleman between you and Domino’s, where
he would take your crypto and then pass the
order, along with payment in dollars, to Domino’s
on your behalf.
The event calls back to one of the foundational
myths of crypto, the 10,000 bitcoin pizza,
the first purchase ever made with cryptocurrency.
“22nd of May, 2010 is the date when someone
first purchased an item with bitcoin, in this
case a pizza.”
The reality of that is very similar to the
Decentraland pizza kiosk: no vendor accepted
bitcoin in exchange for pizza.
Floridian Laszlo Hanyecz offered 10,000 bitcoin
on a forum to anyone who would bring him two
large pizzas.
Fellow Floridian Jeremy Sturdivant took him
up on the offer, bought two large pizzas from
a pizzeria with his own money and then traded
them to Laszlo in exchange for the bitcoin.
Hey, that’s backwards.
Wait, it’s also backwards from this side!
Other groups have tried to recreate amusement
rides in Decentraland, such as those found
in District X.
Originally slated to be Decentraland’s Red
Light District before the project organizer
stole all the donated LAND, District X is
now home to an excellent showcase of the reality
of Decentraland’s ability to deliver interactive
experiences: laggy, glitchy, and profoundly
sad.
Oh yes, I can feel the thrills coursing through
my veins.
In the Decentraland experience there’s a
persistent tension between the different vectors
of incompetence.
Most of the people building this stuff don’t
have good ideas, so the stuff is generally
bad from first principles, but then on top
of that the tools for building things in Decentraland
are also bad, so good ideas are kneecapped
by being extremely hard to implement,
but then on top of that Decentraland just
runs and performs poorly, the controls are
particularly heinous and sometimes the camera
gets possessed by a thousand angry ghosts,
so no matter what experience you build it’ll
be tainted by that mandatory membrane of interaction.
Some of what you’ll stumble across is almost
quaint, like this modern style suburban single
family home populated entirely by official
Nintendo art.
It’s almost adorably incompetent, like the
Decentraland version of a Geocities shrine
to Xander from Buffy the Vampire Slayer.
At least until you notice the For Sale sign
out front, and the several dozen identical
Mario houses scattered around the world, all
owned by the same guy named Dan.
They’re everywhere, I’ve completely lost
track of how many unique instances of this
house I’ve stumbled across.
This is in part because navigating Decentraland
is a nightmare, the extremely short draw distance
and attendant lack of landmarks makes it very
easy to get lost, so it’s hard to tell if
any given Modern Mario House is a fresh one
you’ve never been to before, or one that
you’ve looped back on.
“AUG 1, 2022
DecentRally: Setting the Track for Future
Experience Creators Using Infinity Engine
Code
The first of its kind in Decentraland, DecentRally
shows what the Infinity Engine code can do,
serving as an open source foundation for future
high-speed experiences.”
Decentraland faces a fascinating problem inherent
to its basic construction.
The language of interaction with the world
of Decentraland is the language of games.
You navigate the world via an avatar, your
avatar runs, jumps, and clicks on things.
This makes games the most obvious implementation
as an Experience, since the ludology is already
there.
The problem is that Decentraland is just bad
for games.
DecentRally is an abysmal little experience,
barely qualifying as the kart racer that it
nominally resembles.
Of course we can’t judge it too harshly
as it’s just a proof of concept, though
given that everything in Decentraland seems
to fall under that umbrella it’s enough
to make one suspicious, like maybe “it’s
still in beta” or “it’s just a proof
of concept” are just a rhetorical shield
against criticism.
Either which way, the developer’s other
project, Infinity Engine, is also awful, and
it’s been featured on Decentraland’s front
page for well over a year.
The fantasy of the metaverse is one where
it subsumes much of our present reality, where,
in the words of Matthew Ball “entire generations
will eventually move to and live inside it”
which, as a statement, more or less demands
poetic interpretation, that Ball is referring
to interactions and activity taking place
via the membrane of the software, because
otherwise it’s, you know, stupid, because
your body won’t fit inside the wires.
But regardless, this idea of place requires
the simulacrum of place, and the simulacrum
of place must encompass both the fantastic
and the mundane, because if it doesn’t encompass
both Skyrim and your office and the grocery
store then there’s too much discontinuity,
the metaverse ceases to be a world, a true
place, and becomes little more than a digital
interface, and to that end the existence of
the metaverse demands the existence of Eashoo
Law (A Professional Corporation).
Welcome to the metaverse law office of James
Eashoo, a personal injury lawyer based in
Los Angeles.
James isn’t in right now, no one is, and
he never will be because the idea of staffing
this place with actual people is patently
absurd.
While it was unfortunate that you tripped
and dropped the urn that contained you grandmother’s
ashes because you tripped over a rake that
your roommate left out, unfortunately when
you attacked him with that rake it was a,
uhm, a crime, and so I’m afraid I’m going
to have to refer you to a criminal defense
lawyer.
Uh, this is, this is outside kinda the purview
of what I, what I do, I’m more of a personal
injury lawyer.
So, um, unfortunately you are going to need
criminal defense representation and, um, I
do have some people tha tI can refer you to.
I’m deeply sorry for the loss of your grandmother
and the death of your roommate, but I can’t
assist you any further in this matter.
This is not meaningfully useful in any way
to businesses.
When confronted with the actual product, the
actual series of things that would need to
be engaged with to make the fictional vision
of the metaverse real, the product, and the
comparison to the “next generation of the
internet” is comical.
Ball quotes Tim Sweeny talking about a future
where every company is expected to operate
a virtual world “just as every company a
few decades ago created a webpage, and then
at some point every company created a Facebook
page.”
But here’s the thing: we already know from
those examples that most companies don’t
need much more to a website than some cursory
fluff and their contact information.
A website, to most companies, is just a replacement
for a yellow pages entry, it’s an ad whose
number one job is to carry a phone number,
address, and business hours.
A Facebook page became appealing because it
offloaded the work of designing the page and
its functionality as a whole in a way that
office workers could easily manage: Facebook
handles running Facebook, you just put in
your stuff, making it a useful tool for high
density, up to date communication, like promotions
or changes in operating hours.
The entire process there is a move towards
efficiency.
The construction and maintenance of a virtual
world is ludicrous in comparison.
The effort to build and update is orders of
magnitude beyond even a basic webpage, and
the information density goes down!
Like, this is really important: most business
communication is going to be in the form of
text for… ever, because text is really,
really, really useful.
But the metaverse is a uniquely terrible medium
for the delivery of text because that text
cannot be presented in an optimized format,
it must be bent to the metaphor of a real
space.
That’s why the only actual meaningful things
in Eashoo Law (A Professional Corporation)
are links to conventional, flat, text-and-image
based websites.
Because they’re just more efficient ways
to present and access information.
So the virtual workspace, the idea that this
plot in Decentraland would ever become actually
functional as a space, with the receptionist
navigating up the virtual stairs to tell James,
via in-world voice chat, that someone is waiting
to see him, is comical.
But without that promise, without that story,
what’s even left?
An NFT gallery and hard-to-use widgets that
just open Instagram in another tab and remind
you that you’re not “in the metaverse”
you’re just browsing a website?
I guess at least you can stand on the balcony
and admire the Modern Mario House across the
street.
Even official productions, stuff created by
the developers themselves or people they’ve
sub-contracted, trend heavily towards embarrassing.
The festival stage for the first annual Metaverse
Music Festival featuring DJ Paris Hilton lacked
collision on the stairs and balcony, meaning
you could take a terrible elevator to a second
floor that you would immediately fall through.
New Years Eve 2022 was staged in a Duke-Nukem-esque
recreation of Times Square and featured a
devastatingly terrible jumping puzzle, just
indescribably bad in its fundamental construction,
riddled with all manner of collision problems,
and very much coming off as a half-hearted
idea that was implemented improvisationally
and never actually tested, let alone revised,
with the reward being a broken scavenger token,
z-fighting textures, and a bad view of the
party.
[barely audible fireworks]
“Wait, is that it?
Was that it?”
After a long day’s virtual lawyering, it’s
only natural that you’ll want to take a
load off.
And we would recommend none-other than NFT
World’s NFT World City’s Comedy Club.
It’s always bugged me when I go into a comedy
club and I’m not immediately met with comedy
- it’s false advertising.
But with the power of the metaverse, and a
$120,000 grant from the Decentraland DAO,
the NFT World City’s Comedy Club obtained
an infinite source of comedy.
“Uh, we hope to have content from Decentral
Comedy soon.
And we have also sourced content from an AI
tool called ChatGPT which provides some jokes
for us to show here.
It’s not all comedy and incompetence and
insincerity, though.
Occasionally you’ll stumble across a single
plot that’s just a simple shrine to a loved
one, taken away from this world, too young
and, oh, hey, it’s another Modern Mario
House.
One of the most consistently popular locations
in Decentraland, popular enough to warrant
a functionally permanent spot on the Genesis
Plaza hot locations board, is the WonderMine
meteor mining and crafting game.
Now, something to stress here is that this
is, within the context of Decentraland, a
success story.
There are people who interface with Decentraland
solely as the medium by which they access
WonderMine.
Even just looking at the map it is one of
the few consistently occupied places where
you can find other players in any reasonable
number.
And it is an idle clicking game that is so
sluggish in its pace that it barely qualifies
as a skinner box.
Meteors fall, and you click on them.
And then you wait.
The sole value prospect is that at the end
of the process you might be able to craft
an NFT wearable that you can then sell to
someone else.
“So like I was saying, if you want to see
what this is worth, we can go over to the
marketplace and search steampunk hat and as
you can see its worth 2499 MANA.
And if we want to view the value of MANA today,
it’s over a dollar.”
So with such big money on the line, of course
the game is botted to hell and back with idlers
and auto-clickers.
Decentraland doesn’t log users out after
a set time spent idle, and the meteors fall
in predictable locations, so it’s pretty
easy to automate, but even barring that level
of complexity it’s trivial to just leave
a tab idle and collect the periodic rewards.
Wondermine is also immediately adjacent to
one of the oldest games in Decentraland, Dragon
Rush, which is featured prominently in Genesis
Plaza.
Immediately we can spot a problem with the
real estate model of the internet: this relatively
modest game has an absolutely massive footprint
and necessitates a towering retaining wall
to back its terrain.
From a standpoint of architecture it is an
immensely hostile block, a massive impassable
barrier to both sightlines and traffic.
It turns out that having every individual
app and website take up scarce space in an
adversarial relationship is, uh, bad.
Alright, so, walk onto the dragon’s back,
press f to flap wings and fly, go through
the gates and land on the landing pad to finish
the race.
Now, maybe this is just unfair, after all
I did say that Dragon Rush is one of the oldest
games in Decentraland.
Let’s do some due diligence and find something
more mature, more refined, something with
a budget behind it.
Knights of Antrom, the ultimate role-playing
game that will challenge you to farm, craft,
and fight your way to the top.
Those looking for a little more action to
their Decentraland experience, need look no
further than Dice Masters.
An incredible, fully-playable role-playing
game built within the metaverse’s trusty
framework.
Within its sizable location, gamers can undertake
quests, battle enemies, collect resources
and craft in game items, all in addition to
ridding the realm of the terrible poultry
scourge.
Dice Masters Development and Expansion
Should the following Tier 6: up to $240,000
USD, 6 months vesting (1 month cliff) grant
in the Gaming category be approved?
Yes wins with 93%
Okay, that’s quite a pitch.
And, you know what, let’s treat this seriously,
like let’s treat this like it were a Kickstarter
or Steam Early Access pitch.
$240,000 is modest but realistic, and watching
the trailer, it’s all very achievable, especially
since the buildings are just lifted from World
of Warcraft.
But, like, the features are very straightforward,
and the trailer even evokes Decentraland’s
style.
This is eminently realizable.
Low rent?
Sure.
Devoid of original ideas?
Also true.
Doable?
Absolutely.
This is it, right?
This is the moment Decentraland has been waiting
for, this is the realization of all their
promises!
This isn’t just a thing in Decentraland,
it’s Decentraland as a platform, as the
infrastructure invisible beneath an otherwise
independent game experience!
They even bothered to include the coordinates
in the trailer, like they actually want you
to go there!
[groaning]
It’s just… it’s the same story over
and over again, everywhere you go in Decentraland.
It’s all the same stuff.
No amount of remixing can overcome the underlying
flaws of the base layer.
Decentraland wants to be the invisible tech
behind the scenes, but it can’t because
it also wants to be a real virtual world,
and the one goal imposes endless creative
and technical decisions onto the other.
You can’t really get anything better out
of the system!
The MetaGamiMall is a construction of special
note because its existence was made possible
by a grant of $220,000 US dollars from the
Decentraland DAO, the organization that operates,
in theory, as the government of the Decentraland
world.
The pitch was a gamified mall, and I will
let their own pitch package speak for itself
on some key details.
“Game + Mall = GamiMall”
“The game - super dogerio, the vitality
of the mall.
“The P2E economic model can incentivise
users to play and earn.
“The first comprehensive traffic road system
in Decentaland.
Highly compatible with Customer shopping habits
and Super Dogerio Game.
Interesting piano floor, create more fun while
walking and running.”
“The Meta GamiMall is an avant gard project
endeavor to blur the boundaries between game
and shop activities.
The game lives in the mall, the mall needs
the game.”
The actual product is a track that you walk
along to collect coins that can be traded
for wearables, while a bad techno DJ repeats
the instructions on an endless loop.
Because space is so tight, even for large
plots like this, the track consists mostly
of really obnoxious spirals, and the place
is infested with bots that idle on the exact
same spot until the timer resets and they
can collect more coins.
It would seem that while $220,000 can get
you a lot of stuff, it can’t get you an
experience worth doing with your own human
hands.
The actual rules of Super Dogerio are oblique,
and the DJ’s instructions don’t actually
help.
“Welcome to MetaMine.
MetaMine is a metaverse game event that will
begin from 18th Novermber at MetaGamiMall
in Decentraland.”
“MetaMine is a metaverse game event”
I guess it’s called Metamine now?
As for the mall component, I don’t even
know what to say.
The space is so cluttered with the extreme
cyberspace aesthetic that it’s barely even
legible as a mall, and the whole notion is
keelhauled by the fact that this is a miserable
interface for actually buying things, which
is the actual purpose of a mall.
The result, an empty shopping experience plagued
with bots, isn’t just a dead mall, it’s
an undead mall, stuttering along in a parody
of life.
Now, they did seek a new grant in late 2022,
asking for an additional $60,000 USD to expand
and revitalize the mall.
Unfortunately the proposal was rejected 3
million to 9 million, with 7.8 million of
the “no” votes coming from two people.
Sorry MetaGamiMall, better luck next time.
The Decentraland Report is one of the most
fascinating elements of Decentraland, and
it breaks my heart that we can’t give it
the time it truly deserves.
They style themselves as “the first ever
decentralized news network, reporting on the
latest breaking news of the Metaverse”.
Between grants and private funding it has
received over $250,000 USD, a quarter million
dollars of investment.
It is an organization operated by Kevin Clark,
better known by his handle KevinOnEarth999.
We’ll let him explain what it means:
“Decentralized news networks give the public
the power to control event coverage, reporters
and how the network will evolve over time.
Tokens are distributed to the public based
on participation and can be used to purchase
event coverage, ad space, and vote on key
decisions - such as the addition or removal
of actual news reporters.”
Just to stress this, to highlight it and make
sure that you are aware that this is not us
catastrophizing or editorializing, the ability
for the crowd to fire reporters is an explicit
feature.
“Imagine if you could use a token to vote
off a reporter from the news.”
You can buy the ability to fire a reporter.
And that’s deliberate, because it gives
the token resale value, which incentivises
participation.
The editorial agenda of the Decentraland Report
is not just nominally available for purchase,
it is proudly available for purchase.
The Decentraland Report is a news outlet that
hates journalism.
It takes the very messy subject of journalistic
independence, the way that journalism often
functions as willing collaborators with systemic
power, and the reasons why we should be legitimately
skeptical, alert, and literate in how we intake
media, and uses that to advocate for a radical
populism masquerading as neutrality.
The logic is that institutions are inherently
biased, therefore less institution means less
bias, and no institution means no bias.
Their trust model is explicitly rooted in
their incompetence.
Kevin’s rhetoric is part and parcel with
the conspiratorial thinking that leads people
to trust misinformation they found on Facebook
specifically because they found it on a page
that gets flagged by Facebook as misinformation.
It shares a table with the belief that reporters
exist to deceive the public, and so the only
journalism you can trust comes from those
who hate journalism.
“With this decentralized approach to news,
the public can take control of global narratives
and focus on fact-based reporting verses biased-based
reporting which is focused more on getting
views than telling the truth.
Kevin’s vision for the news is downright
dystopian, it’s a killer writing prompt
if you’re in need of ideas.
So what’s the product?
You want to see some journalism so unprofessional
that it would make even the writers at the
Defiant cringe?
“Any giveaways?
Yeah, for sure man!
If you hang around I’ll definitely do a
giveaway man!
So we’re just hop right on in here to Dice
Masters.
Come on through!
I just want to show support to Dice Masters.”
“And then we’ll kinda move into the auction
phase, hopping from gallery to gallery.”
“That is, that sounds like a great time.”
“As recommended by Seanny, upon the passing
of the grant, we agree to pay back 10% of
our monthly revenue to the DAO, in perpetuity
until the grant amount is paid back to the
DAO.
That’s amazing.
That, to me, is epic.”
It’s just Twitch streams.
“No fucking way!
Do you fucking hear that motherfuckers!
That’s what the fucking metaverse was missing!
Metal!”
“That is very true, holy shit.
That is very frickin’ true.
Wow.
That was Big Dave.
Says Big Dave is Talking, listen the fuck
up.
Wow.
That was, wow.
That was sound check?
You gotta be kidding me!
That was frickin’ sound check, you gotta
be kidding me!”
I know, I know, right?
It’s pretty disappointing that after all
that talk about the philosophy of journalism
this ship runs aground over the fact that
nothing remotely worth reporting on happens
in Decentraland in the first place, so the
risk of journalistic malpractice is functionally
zero.
Despite the lofty ambitions of the network,
these guys are ultimately harmless.
They’re just small streamers cosplaying
as reporters while hanging out with their
handful of regulars talking about the video
game they like to play.
That said, there’s still a story here.
They still raised a quarter million dollars,
right?
Did that at least pay someone?
Well, no.
Reporters aren’t “paid” as such.
They get paid in the REPORT token, and they
get a cut of the organizations’ monthly
revenue on Xpand, a crypto-meets-Twitter-meets-Patreon
platform.
At time of writing that’s around $120 bucks,
total.
Xpand takes a 10% cut, there is another 10%
cut for their grant repayment, a phrase that
shouldn’t exist, and then the remainder
is split nine ways.
There’s the possibility of one-time donations
on top of that, which get cut the same way,
but on average the individual reporters are
looking at about ten bucks a month.
This uh, isn’t a great deal, especially
since the streamers,
Sorry, reporters
Need to provide their own equipment.
So it's no surprise that Kevin has failed
to draw in any Pulitzer Prize winners.
Who he’s ended up with is an ensemble of
Decentraland users who just want to grow their
stream by associating with an org.
They’re all broadcasting from their personal
Twitch streams, what they get from the org
is the DCLR branding, which, you know, it
doesn’t draw in the crowds.
Every single stream we caught had extremely
low viewership, almost always fewer than 10
viewers, often under 5.
Kevin's personal and DCLR branded YouTube
channels don’t fare any better - a video
is a success if it breaks 100 views.
So, where on (Kevin)OnEarth did the money
go?
Okay, the reporters only get paid from the
Xpand pot, DCLR doesn’t buy them lights
or webcams, the only thing left to even spend
it on… is Decentraland itself?
[Kazoo and fart performance of Also Sprach
Zarathustra]
The Decentraland Report is the perfect showcase
of web3’s ability to cause money to just
evaporate.
The build is called the Metaflower, which
is a reference to an NFT of a superyacht from
other metaverse candidate The Sandbox that
sold
Know what, doesn’t matter.
Using allegedly very expensive tech, the flower
is intended to develop and bloom as the number
of subscribers on the Xpand page grows.
Of course we need to take Kevin’s word on
that because the count is currently 22 followers
toward the goal of 10,000.
So the building has remained in its initial
form.
What we’re left with is this.
We’ve got walls laced with Kevin’s prized
NFTs, two platforms that I’m assured are
the ‘studios’ where presenters are intended
to stand.
The Decision Room, where DCLR DAO members
will meet, once the DAO gets some.
And then we have the butthole tunnel that
takes us to an alien in a rice paddy hat who
tells us that we need to save the Decentraland
Report by gathering News Juice.
And it turns out that News Juice means ‘please
follow Kevin and pals on Twitter.’
Wait, Kevin’s in here twice!
Strangely there’s no news in the DCLR HQ.
What they do give you is a link to an entirely
different 3D web application called Oncyber.
So you’re sitting there, computer frying
from running Decentraland.
And if you want to see some news at the metaverse
news building, Kevin wants you to open up
another 3D site that loads up two dozen YouTube
videos at once and then crashes Firefox entirely
- it’s absurd.
Needless to say, the Decentraland build contributes
extremely little to the utility of running
a news network.
We don’t know precisely how much this whole
thing cost beyond about $35,000 for the LAND,
but given that the $127,000 in grants are
reasonably well accounted for it would seem
that, after the boring stuff like building
the website and Twitch assets, this as a whole
represents Kevin’s $126,000.
So let’s focus in on those grants.
Kevin received 4 grants from the Decentraland
DAO.
Two were to hire an editor for DCLR - both
paid the editor $50 per edit… in MANA.
Then there was a $5000 grant in September
of 2021 to create unique in-game jackets for
reporters as a milestone reward for 6 months
work.
And then there was the big one, a $120,000
US grant in stable coins to build the backend
for DCLR’s reward system.
Since decentralized news is all about rewarding
participation, including viewership, you need
to build that system.
Pretty much the same tech that handles Twitch
drops… to service a community of like 30
people max.
The decentralized philosophy of the project
demands this type of massive, inefficient
system exist as a starting point.
You can’t expand into these solutions naturally.
So Kevin spent $35,000 on LAND, potentially
$91,000 on the studio build, $5,000 on jackets,
and $120,000 on this reward system, and then
went back to the grant program looking for
another $240,000, 32 of which was allotted
to reporter equipment and included salaries
for a marketing director, content manager,
graphic designer and so on.
In what seems to have been the only lucid
moment in the fever dream of the grant scheme,
Kevin was told…
no.
Two more reduced proposals have also been
rejected.
You know what we haven’t talked about in
a while?
Chocolate.
I mean, sure, Lindt has their metaverse, but
surely chocolate giant Hershey wouldn’t
be left behind.
Well, if you’ve got a craving, you’re
in luck!
Just a hop skip and a jump from the Sugar
Club you can experience Hersheyverse, the
official Metaverse holiday home of Hershey
Chocolates (of India and the Philippines).
Sure this plot may look microscopic, but boy
howdy is there a lot to do.
For one you can talk to the shopkeepers inside
and they’ll… send you a link to Amazon.
But there’s also gamification!
There’s a quest!
It’s time for a treasure hunt!
Just hop up here and bounce over here, and
click on this, and ride the elevator and click
on the camera and you can get your very own
official Hersheyverse wearable.
An NFT on the frequently exploited Polygon
blockchain, it would appear that this hat
has been claimed, generously, about 500 times.
But once you claim your extremely ugly hat
you get one last quest to extend your time
in the Hersheyverse.
You see the treasure chest needs opening,
and the keys won’t find themselves, so you
just, talk to the shopkeepers and pick the
keys up off the ground, and click the thing,
and gain the ability to fly!
And by fly I mean that if you double jump
an invisible platform spawns under you and
lifts you up to a predetermined height, where
you can jump to one of the clouds and take
control of the chocolate cannon which may
or may not work.
Brands love the metaverse.
Or at least that’s the story.
Samsung, Nissan, Vodafone, Snapple, CitiBank,
Pedigree, Hershey, Mountain Dew, Trident,
Sour Patch Kids, Atari, Miller Lite, JP Morgan,
everyone’s getting in on the metaverse!
Now, what that means is, uh, extremely flexible.
We’ve already dipped into Hersheyverse,
but what else is out there?
It’s just… it’s weird, man.
Atari has probably the best looking location
of any of these, but it still principally
consists of a large faux-social space full
of furniture that you can’t interact with.
Wait, have I even mentioned that yet?!
Yeah, you can’t sit on chairs in Decentraland!
The whole goddamn world is built of nothing
but hangout spots and you can’t even role
play sitting around a table unless you buy
the user-created Sit emote from the marketplace!
Otherwise in the atari stronghold you have
a slate of links that all take you out of
Decentraland and a couple wearables that are
no longer available.
The only thing to actually do here is play
one of the four variants of Breakout and feel
the gnawing cold reality seep into you as
you realize that Decentraland is such a monumental
failure as a platform for socialization, for
commerce, and for gaming that it can’t even
handle properly emulating Breakout, a game
from 1976 that you can play on goddamn Google
images!
Steve Wozniak built Breakout fifty years ago
to run on 44 TTL chips and a ham sandwich
and that’s still somehow too demanding a
gaming experience for Decentraland.
The Onyx Lounge by JP Morgan Chase, built
in March 2022 and described by Fortune as
a bet on “a metaverse future that could
be worth trillions” was originally staffed
only by a wandering tiger, but has since been
replaced with a cramped reading lounge.
The DCL branch of HSBC is a unique kind of
awful, with this deeply unsettling robot receptionist
and stairs with no collision, with the only
problem being that it’s not clear if this
is an official HSBC project or not, since
impersonation is trivial and even the official
builds are glitchy and weird, because it’s
Decentraland: everything is glitchy and weird.
Particularly though, as you go through a lot
of these you start to notice a few trends.
First is a subject that we’ll talk about
at length later, which is that discussion
of these ventures rarely feature anything
meaningful.
They don’t tend to tell you how to actually
find the location, and tend to downplay the
product itself, typically limiting visuals
to a wide screenshot of an exterior, if anything
at all.
Fortune didn’t even bother to mention the
tiger.
It’s really more about the headline than
the actual space.
Second is a trend of dispersion.
It’s not Hershey’s that’s in the metaverse,
it’s Hershey’s India and Philippines,
it’s Nissan Italy, it’s Vodafone Turkey.
Third is a trend towards the temporary.
While the Atari metaverse headquarters is
still standing and the Onyx Lounge by JP Morgan
Chase still sort of technically exists, most
of these aren’t actually brands “moving
to the metaverse”, they’re just promotional
campaigns.
The Snapple Stronghold, Miller Lite Metalite
Bar, and Hersheyverse are already gone.
“And look, we’ve heard there aren’t
a lot of people inside the Metaverse yet,
but marketers say it's gonna be a very big
deal…”
The Meataversity of Steak-umm came and went
in about two months.
The Trident Vibe x Sour Patch Kids Chew The
Vibes Dance Party has been replaced by an
“office” for MoZeus Worldwide, the ad
agency that built it.
While a few corporations jumped in early and
actually bought LAND, that ship has seemingly
already sailed, and now the impetus for this
isn’t originating with the brands but with
the digital ad agencies that they hire, who
then toss in a Decentraland “activation”
as part of the package, a way to recoup some
value from the LAND that the ad agency bought.
Fourth is that they just overwhelmingly suck
and need to constantly direct users out of
Decentraland in order to accomplish anything.
The Nissan experience will let you book a
test drive in Italy if you click a link to
open their existing website.
The Atari store opens Atari’s actual store.
The Pedigree Fosterverse lets LAND holders
create a metaverse duplicate of a real dog
in a partnered shelter in need of a forever
home.
The metaverse dog serves as a digital billboard
leading to the dog’s adoptapet page.
Of the three dogs the platform lists at time
of writing, all three have long-since been
adopted out, but their listings remain because
the incentive for landholders to participate
is to get a Pedigree branded dog on their
parcel - so the metaverse dogs are doomed
to beg for adoption for all eternity.
So what does that all mean?
Well, the obvious, but speculative, narrative
is that ad agencies that have a stake in the
success of “the metaverse” are approaching
brands in smaller markets and pitching them
on a vision of “the future” and dazzling
them with some cooked numbers.
They point to articles in real outlets like
Fortune with titles referencing a trillion
dollar future, and, like, in the face of that
can you even afford the possibility of being
wrong?
It’s the lamest version of Pascal’s Wager.
Back on the Genesis Plaza spawn platform we’ve
got these pillars that I’ve shown but not
really talked about yet.
These are Decentraland’s solution to discoverability
in their metaverse, or, well, at least one
of their attempted solutions.
As already mentioned, the Classics pillar
includes Dragon Rush in the coveted bottom
spot where you can actually interact without
needing to crank the camera or use the awkward
skeuomorphic buttons.
On the right hand side, though, is the Crowds
pillar, and for the last year one location
has dominated that bottom slot.
ICE Poker - The Stronghold, which routinely
boasts over 100 attendees, often pushing 200.
Now, that number is middling in isolation,
but by the standards of Decentraland, where
12 qualifies as a crowd, it’s pretty meaningful.
Of course a ton of those attendees are idle
at the default spawn location, but let’s
not ruin the fun.
As for the legality of this, well, the opinion
of Decentra Games’ Singapore-based lawyers
is that it’s not gambling under relevant
statutes, thus they don’t need a gaming
license to operate.
The important thing here is that the only
thing in Decentraland that seems to be actually
successful is outright just a casino, and
regardless of the sentiment of Jacque Law
LLC, the community seems to be taking it for
what it clearly is.
“So as you can see I’ve earned $2.98 from
playing.
And honestly I’ve only been gambli~oops
playing the casino for a couple of days.”
The odd thing is that it’s seemingly only
the poker tables, at that.
Like, really it’s just this one specific
casino.
There’s a whole bunch of different casinos
around the gambling zone, basically all of
them owned by DecentraGames under the ICE
brand, but The Stronghold is the only one
anyone’s ever in.
Turns out that’s because they already ran
into legal problems!
You used to be able to gamble on the slots
at Tominoya with your cryptocurrency directly,
but between glitchy behavior that would eat
transactions, high service fees, long wait
times to resolve bets, and, most critically,
some pointed letters from various regulatory
bodies, The Stronghold is the only location
that supports the current brown bag policy,
and it only has poker, all the others have
been converted to free-play.
You can still go over to The Aquarium and
play blackjack, but you will do so alone,
these people are not here to play, they are
here to gamble.
When discussing Decentraland, it’s hard
to overlook the subject of its abysmal user
base.
Indeed, the biggest story to come out of Decentraland
in 2022 was drama over DCL’s metrics.
In October 2022, crypto outlet Coindesk reported
on DappRadar’s Data that claimed Decentraland
had as few as 38 daily active users.
Decentraland fired back in a blog post, scrutinizing
the data, calling it misinformation, and pushing
their own value of 8,000.
This back and forth continued, with Coindesk
releasing the ‘final word’ on the subject
in January 2023 - with their research suggesting
an active daily user base of 810.
Now, it’s tempting to fall into this whirlpool,
as apparently Coindesk did for 3 months, and
litigate the definition of a “user,” but
let’s head this off at the pass.
Whether Decentraland has daily activity of
40 users, 800 users or 8000 users is irrelevant,
in their business these are all the same number.
Emotionally it feels like a significant difference.
But let’s give some context to these numbers.
At 810 users, It's competing with Lord of
the Rings Online and it has a fraction of
the users of Fishing Planet - which like,
it’s Fishing Planet.
The most generous numbers for Decentraland
put it in competition with Star Wars: The
Old Republic.
All of these values are just Steam users,
it doesn’t include the users who access
the games directly through their dedicated
launchers or on other platforms, so these
numbers are inherently conservative.
Despite having these varying player counts,
these games all have fundamentally the same
business model.
They are operating a micro-MMO.
If you ever wonder how ‘dead MMOs’ survive,
it’s by running tight ships.
These teams, often small, inherit a product
that was hugely expensive to produce five,
ten, fifteen years ago, and they are tasked
with maintaining it in order to support a
small but loyal user base.
It is possible for Runes of Magic to be profitable
off the back of a single digit number of ‘whales’,
people who just really like Runes of Magic.
The same is true for Fiesta Online or LotRO.
So it doesn’t matter what Decentraland’s
true daily user count looks like, because
any number they’ve ever pushed falls into
the same band of ‘long, long dead MMO.’
The fact that Decentraland has a similar user
base to DC Universe Online is the red flag
that most people notice first.
Daybreak Game Company is a game developer
that currently owns and maintains numerous
old MMOs.
Including Everquest, DC Universe Online, and
Lord of the Rings Online.
This is a tough business, and in December
of 2020, Daybreak was acquired by Enad Global
7, in an agreement valued at $300 million
dollars.
So this company, that owns and maintains all
of these MMOs that are all individually comparable
to Decentraland’s user base, is meant to
be worth a fraction of Decentraland?
“And this is the story behind the company
worth nearly ten billion dollars at the market
peak.”
It’s been said numerous times before, but
it shouldn’t be left unsaid here.
Decentraland’s purported value, based on
the market cap of its cryptocurrency, is completely
disconnected from reality.
Decentraland’s product is clearly trash.
As a video game, it struggles to set itself
apart from Inferna, an MMO that advertises
itself as an underdog off the back of its
“3 man dev team.”
So Decentraland goes all-in on the speculation,
on narrative.
Its value has nothing to do with what Decentraland
is today.
But what it will be… and what it did do
when you weren’t watching.
“Because the metaverse in its more mature
form will be a lot more advanced than this
and a lot more sophisticated than this, but
this really is how it starts.
This is the beginning of it and you know this
is going to be the shape of things for the
next twenty to thirty years, I really believe
that.”
The way that crypto users talk about Decentraland
is so dissociated from what you yourself witness,
that it seems like they’re talking about
an entirely different thing.
Like is this it?
Is this the billion dollar virtual world?
Surely I must be missing something.
“I’m sorry you don’t like to make money
here in the network”
Like so much of web3, Decentraland has weaponized
its speculative element.
Since they are the future, the product as
it exists now borders on irrelevant.
The proposed inevitability of the metaverse
is their greatest asset - because they don’t
even need to try.
This is the everything-proof shield that Decentraland
users have created to guard from criticism.
Decentraland and all its contents is forever
a prototype - always just an indication of
what the future will bring.
Being bad is not a fatal flaw in the crypto
space.
Just look at the Red Ape Family, they’re
visibly incompetent and they still made it
to three episodes, even if the creator is
too much of a coward to post the third.
Every successful crypto project is bad, but
with enough legitimacy you can mask that fact.
This generates extremely funny scenarios,
like crypto shill Robin from The Defiant stumbling
through Decentraland’s barren wasteland
while trying to invent reasons why what he’s
looking at isn’t plainly obviously ass.
“And I often say that the Metaverse is…
it’s a world that rotates around you.
And this is what I mean, the world literally
does rotate around you, this is… it’s
a universe where you’re always at the center.
That is the whole kind of mindset change that
you have to get when you talk about the metaverse.”
Decentraland users understand this need for
legitimacy intuitively, and so it becomes
what they crave above all else.
That is why they value brand activations so
highly, no matter the circumstances.
Being able to put “Vodafone” on their
world map, or “Pedigree” in their events
tab, spins the narrative that real companies
are here in Decentraland.
Even embarrassing brand activations are defended,
because “they’re just dipping their toes
in, this is just the beginning.”
Decentraland users seek to encourage brand
activations and events through pathetic pandering.
They’ll smile through gritted teeth as they
insist that the Hershey’s Experience really
is interesting and successful.
By performatively engaging with events and
brand activations, users seek to create the
illusion that these events are successful
in the hopes of drawing in the next sucker.
“What’s cooking good looking people.
We’re in Decentraland and we’re in Hersheyverse.
Can you believe that?
Hershey’s bro, Hershey.
However you say that, Hershey.
Pretty sure it’s Hershey, the fuck bro Mandela?
Bro.
Who woulda thought that Hershey was gonna
make a little plot on Decentraland.
You know before you know it you’re gonna
see other candy companies.
You know there’s already beverage companies,
there’s already alcohol companies, there’s
fucking Yahoo, Amazon is already in here,
and Hershey is the next big one to get into
this shit.”
This principle scales up from the Pedigree
Fosterverse all the way up to the marquee
events of the platform.
The Metaverse Music Festival, which in its
most recent outing was tossed around as having
featured performances from Bjork, Ozzy Ozzbourne,
and Mötorhead, consisted almost entirely
of pre-recorded messages from the musicians
followed by just playing a couple music videos.
“It’s awesome to be in the Metaverse with
you and it feels great to be here in Decentraland.
I hope you’re all having an amazing time
today.
My name is Dave Mustaine from Megadeath and
today I’ll be playing you a few of my favorite
tracks.
Let me know what you think about this one.”
[Opening chords of The Sick, The Dying, and
The Dead]
I criticized Fortnite for being overly poetic
with its definition of a “live” Marshmallow
concert, and this is just, this is just so
much worse.
The Metaverse Fashion Week, as the name implies,
was a week-long fashion event held in Decentraland
in March of 2022, scheduled to run just after
the Milan Fashion Week.
The event was organized by the Decentraland
Foundation, the developers of Decentraland.
It was the involvement of the Foundation that
saw the Metaverse Fashion Week get some real
attention and media coverage.
A number of lifestyle, fashion, and tech journalists
were sent in to cover the event, for whom
many were experiencing the metaverse for the
first time.
The event was billed as an opportunity to
see the next major innovation in the fashion
industry.
A new way for fashion to be designed, bought
and sold.
It would be the melding of fashion and art.
Finally, art and fashion - together at last.
The word ‘phygital’ got thrown around
a lot, to refer to the simultaneous purchasing
of a digital and physical good.
Like you buy a digital hat in Decentraland,
and a real hat turns up in the mail.
Not to get distracted, but World of Warcraft
did this exact promotion in 2010.
This plush Wind Rider Cub came with an in-game
pet, it’s not a new thing.
But of course, they don’t frame it that
way; instead you’re buying a single hat
with two simultaneous planes of existence.
It’s not a bundle of two products, it’s
the same hat in two different forms.
There are dozens of tech startups eager to
composite clothing over photo or video and
label it as the future of self-expression.
This so-called ‘screen wear’ is at its
best, an artful photoshop job, and at worst,
essentially just a Tiktok or Zoom filter.
“There are different avenues.
So the first thing is you could wear it on
your real self through an AR filter.
So that’s number one, and that’s the part
where technology is still, you know, a work
in progress.
It's going to get better and better, we know
it.
So I think as we, regular people, start
transitioning more and more into the virtual
world, spending more time in virtual environments
and that barrier between physical and digital
starts blurring more and more, and we will
start consuming digital fashion, digital sneakers,
digital makeup, digital jewelry”
This was the rhetoric that defined the Metaverse
Fashion Week.
So, our ragtag ensemble of journalists and
creators were sent in to report on the future
of reality and fashion.
How did it go?
Do you really need to be told at this point?
[annoying sounds from DCL]
“What the fuck did I just watch?”
“After a pre-show trial session spent exploring
Decentraland’s ‘Luxury Fashion District’—maybe
it was too early, but the only fashion space
I teleported to was an empty DKNY store.
“While there were plenty of fashion shows,
very few were successful because the overall
experience fell flat.
Perhaps expectedly, many weren’t able to
capture the magic of a physical show, where
attendees are fully immersed and emotionally
invested in the brand’s collection.
The game-ified aesthetic in Decentraland took
away from the fantasy and craftsmanship of
luxury fashion and, simply put, the avatar
models weren’t as inspiring.
“I don’t know how I feel about it.
I literally canceled everything including
my workout to watch this show.”
And there was just very little documenting
of the event in general.
This is due to a combination of disinterest,
but also a deliberate effort not to showcase
the embarrassing product.
Even the brands involved in the show downplayed
the Decentraland part of their Decentraland
show.
“The shows didn’t look the way the brands
expected they would, as publications on their
social networks made clear.
This is because brands posted the best photos
from the show and not the reality of pixelated
avatars and simple looks.”
Likewise, musicians who “performed” at
the music festival didn’t exactly rush to
show off the event, either, so footage of
any of these theoretically big events is shockingly
sparse.
This isn’t some grand conspiracy, it’s
just dozens of individuals independently reaching
the same conclusion: the product sucks and
it’d be a bad idea to show it.
This is true for both DCL users, but also
the journalists covering it.
Decentraland looks so unprofessional that
coverage of DCL looks unprofessional by extension.
“And this actually looks, it looks sorta
like me.
I like it so much I’m going to dance for
you.”
“We do have a whisky distillery”
“You’ve been holding out.
Oh, this is cool.”
“Here we can walk around and actually see
the distillery from the inside.”
“I enjoy your virtual distillery, not so
much your virtual bourbon, so cheers Gigi.”
“Cheers to that!”
“I mean, so here’s the thing, uh, is it
for us, I don’t know, but there are hundreds
of thousands of people who already live in
the metaverse, who exist in the metaverse,
who are buying things or hanging out.”
This creates an environment where the Metaverse
Fashion Week was a thing talked about in the
abstract.
It was a thing that did happen, but the reality
is slowly eroded away.
Most people who learned about the event didn’t
see the product, they only heard the narrative.
And that narrative went a little something
like this:
“The wearables were supposed to be available
immediately after the runway event at a nearby
pop-up shop, and for free — a rarity considering
fashion’s rush to capitalize on crypto clothing.
For some reason, a couple of hours after it
ended, they weren’t displayed yet inside
the paisley-patterned store.
A good reason to come back.”
This journalist witnessed a broken feature,
they experienced a bug.
Rather than reporting critically on the failure
of a key feature of the event, the article
pulls its punch in the last line through the
language of puff journalism.
Out of context, it reads almost like satire.
But if you read enough coverage of Decentraland,
this becomes a very real trend.
“Last of all, I can definitely see this
event evolving into something much more engaging.
there are communities of people who are replicating
in various metaverse outposts behaviors that
people (or people dressed as elves) have long
cultivated in reality.
And fashion is one of those behaviors.
So we’re all just going to need a better
graphics card.
“However, MVFW did provide a glimpse into
possibilities for how brands can build their
narratives in the metaverse—offering immersive
experiences and innovative ways to expand
offerings beyond the physical.
“Once VR glasses are integrated the experience
is going to be on a whole other level.”
And in the absence of any voices to the contrary,
that becomes the narrative of the Metaverse
Fashion Week.
It had ‘some technical issues’, ‘reviews
were mixed’, but it was a proof of concept
that left journalists feeling certain that
the concept has a future.
And through that lens, that allows those involved
to say with a straight face that the event
was a success.
“It was a fantastic four days.
As a proof-point of what is to come; this
is the early evolution of decentralized commerce”
On the whole, journalists are seemingly overwhelmed
by the tempest of claims and ideas surrounding
the metaverse.
We can appreciate why this is the case; a
lot of this is vague either on purpose or
on accident.
It is not the job of the writers at Women’s
Wear Daily to crack crypto wide open.
It’s all too big, too out of scope, they’re
convinced that they “just don’t get it.”
So they defer to the explanations and narratives
given to them by people trying to sell something.
“I mean, so here’s the thing, I…”
Eric Ravenscraft has discussed this phenomenon
with a specific eye towards journalists in
outlets like the New York Times uncritically
parroting the vocabulary of real estate for
the digital groundbreaking of metaverse headquarters
that in many cases don’t even actually exist.
This goes all the way back to the first major
coverage given to Decentraland - A BBC story
in 2018 in response to the initial land auction.
“In Decentraland users can build whatever
they can imagine on plots of virtual land.
But the creators are giving BBC Tending a
sneak peek.”
What’s important to remember here is that
the Decentraland we’re seeing wouldn’t
exist for another 2 years, the actual product
in 2018 looked like this.
So by its very nature there is nothing really
to show.
And it means we get these lovely little artifacts
from the past.
“Right, whoah, I seem to be on some sort
of dance floor, I can hear music, it’s very
colourful.
So there seems to be a zombie out in the distance.
Oh gosh, he’s coming right at me!”
“It’ll be pretty much exactly like Facebook
except you’ll be able to hear and see each
other in VR.
So a bit more of a real experience.
As long as we’ve got the internet, stick
our headsets on, and I’ll be able to have
friends come round my house in Decentraland,
or I can go to their house for a virtual cup
of tea.”
“How high would the price have to get for
you to sell that land?”
“I’m not selling it until it’s worth
at least $10 million.”
“Ten million?”
“Yeah.”
He sold for $980 a year later.
“A million dollars!
But it doesn’t exist?”
“It does here, and it will do, in about
a year I believe.”
The spine of this story is built not on what
Decentraland did, or was doing, but what it
will do.
All of the features that will be implemented
and benchmarks it will hit.
Journalists and vloggers who very understandably
don’t know the deep lore of Decentraland’s
development still mention VR as a thing that
just hasn’t been implemented yet, despite
the feature being scrapped.
“Once VR glasses are integrated the experience
is going to be on a whole other level.”
Decentraland craves legitimacy, but it can
subsist on crumbs.
It is a speculative real estate scheme which
is rapidly approaching the Nigerian Prince
level of self-selection.
That means that for its purpose, all it needs
is for people to discuss it, and for the conversation
to feature the defenses we’ve been discussing.
It’s just a prototype, it will improve,
the metaverse is inevitable.
Because this reporting loads the bases for
investment advice like this to sound believable.
“Land is hitting all time highs for value
and people are asking ‘can people really
afford to buy these plots for a lot?
Yes because there’s going to be large commercial
and business entities that are going to be
able to make a lot more than what they’re
going to pay for this land - they know it.
It has long term ramifications in the industry,
so it’s a great investment.”
If you took Kevin’s advice at the time,
you’d be in the red less than two weeks
later, have lost half your investment 2 months
later and be down 80 to 90% today.
That is the danger posed by nonchalant coverage
of Decentraland, boosting the narrative that
major brands and mass adoption are right around
the corner.
There’s no such thing as bad publicity for
Decentraland.
It continues to subsist through performative
hype and deception.
Decentraland needs to be recognized for what
it is, and can’t be given the easy way out.
Decentraland is not, and has never been, a
VR experience.
You cannot order a pizza in Decentraland.
Decentraland is not the future.
It has never, and will never be, worth a billion
dollars.
So at this point I think it’s plain to see
that the product of Decentraland is, at best,
bad.
But Decentraland users are battle-hardened
on this point - they’ve had years of defending
against this claim.
Many DCL users will concede that sure, the
product itself is janky, but obviously its
just a prototype - and the real appeal of
Decentraland, what sets it apart from its
competition, is its system of governance.
Decentraland was built and is maintained by
‘the Foundation’, the actual developers
behind the product.
Meilich and Ordano always intended for the
Foundation to go hands-off, simply becoming
the underlying machinery of the world akin
to the invisibility of a web host.
As part of this invisibility, they wanted
users to handle as many elements of development
and maintenance as possible.
This is characterized through the language
of ownership - Decentraland is “owned by
its users”, so naturally the users have
direct control over the product.
This is further obfuscated through the language
of Decentraland as a reified space - which
is to say, Decentraland users present themselves
as akin to the government of a virtual world
- enacting policies in a democratic fashion.
They do this through the Decentraland DAO.
Because the Decentraland DAO dresses itself
in the language of governance and law, it’s
tempting to engage with them on that level
and take the DAO seriously.
We tried to give them a fair go, but we found
ourselves repeating the mistakes of the journalists
we just criticized.
To contrast them against real governments
implies that the comparison is warranted,
and humors the notion that these are adults
attempting to revolutionize the concept of
governance.
So let’s adjust expectations and lead with
the soul of the DAO.
Upon revisiting the DAO’s governance site
for this project, the first thing that caught
our eye was this.
A proposal to fire a Committee member for
abuse of power and bias.
And let me tell you, the contents of this
would be right at home on Something Awful
circa 2008.
A guy got banned on Discord and got so upset
that he wrote a 1000-word essay on a sock
puppet about why the moderator should be fired
for abusing their authority.
Because when asked, the moderator kinda said
he was a pluralist and “pluralists hate
the individual.”
And on and on it goes.
The proposal was rejected, but it was rejected
as an invalid question because the Team Manager
of the DAO Facilitation Squad does not count
as a member of the DAO Committee, and thus
a complaint would need to be made to the Grant
Support Squad who would then need to recommend
a proposal to revoke the grant funding the
DAO Facilitation Squad, thus firing Matimio
indirectly.
Then there’s Kevin’s failed grant proposal
- where multiple people rejected the proposal
at least in part because Kevin blocked them
on Twitter.
When you block someone on Twitter, this is
where they end up.
This is a group of people that sees the Sugar
Club, the empty bar next to Hershey’s, requesting
$60,000 US dollars to fund its “operating
costs” - and they’re like yeah that seems
reasonable.
When they hold elections, the candidates are
asked questions like: “What are each candidate's
stance on bringing physical world ideologies
into our decentralized world?
You know, government structures - democracy,
communism, whatever.”
In that example, the candidates universally
accepted the idea that DCL was apolitical
- and they would support politics being patched
into Decentraland, but only if it achieved
majority support in an official vote.
“This is like a grand experiment, however
there’s a lot at stake so I think any ideology
that we’re considering bringing in it would
be best handled on a side-project.”
My dudes, the ideology is coming from inside
the house.
Their philosophy of governance minimizes individual
authority and decision-making.
But they pass phaux-legislation that gives
committee members absolute discretion with
no appeals process.
The Decentraland DAO is no less of a failure
than the Hershey’s Experience or DecentRally
- we’re just changing gears from bad video
games to bureaucratic incompetence.
You can’t really understand the DAO until
you wrap your head around just how inequitable
the voting situation is.
DAOs often makes use of weighted voting schemes.
The main purpose of this is to ‘acknowledge
a user’s stake in the project’ - the logic
being that those with the most invested have
the most at stake in the DAO.
Though the details can vary between DAO’s,
Decentraland’s scheme is refreshingly straight
forward.
Votes are weighted based on the sum of Decentraland
tokens in the attached wallet.
1 MANA is worth 1 point of Vote Power.
It’s just wealth, the more money you have,
the more your vote counts - one to one.
Naturally, this leads to those with wealth
shutting down any proposal that bothers them.
For instance - Let’s look at this proposal.
“Should we address the Voting Power Distribution
in the DAO?”
In the proposal, a DAO Committee member pointed
out the obvious issues of the system.
And the results turned out like this.
163 votes for, 45 against.
That is 78% support in terms of ‘real’
votes, though we’ll get to that, but once
Voting Power was accounted for, the margin
inverted, to 73% against.
And then even within that, of the 5.18 million
VP against the proposal, 4 million came from
a single wallet.
4 wallets make up almost all of the votes
against the proposal - 99.7% of the VP in
the 73% majority.
The next step would naturally be to play with
these figures versus the real votes, you know
‘2% of voters accounted for 73% of the VP’
- but the issue there is that even though
this weighted system allegedly exists to combat
bots, users still use bots for the optics.
When you actually look at the votes, 128 of
the 209 votes were from accounts with 0 VP.
These were accounts with literally no influence
on the vote.
80% of those dummy votes were for Yes.
19 of these accounts only had a single VP,
and then a bunch had 2 VP - both equally capable
of being socket puppets.
But whether Guest#60fd is a real user or not
is irrelevant - because one wallet lapped
the competition.
One wallet told the DAO go to [static] itself,
just really [static], and the DAO politely
complied.
These whales are often burner accounts who
are not available for negotiation, their
decrees are silent, yet drown out all other
voices.
But there is still an urge to pretend like
negotiation is a possibility.
“But we still did get it denied.
Although we met the threshold of approval
in the final hours we did get 3 votes which
came in to deny and sort of made us step back
and say we need to re-evaluate how we’re
bringing this forward because ultimately even
reaching the VP threshold of approval by the
community, it seems like the whales still
felt like something else needed to be addressed
outside of the other feedback that we had.”
Kevin is clearly upset by this, and despite
all his talk about “addressing the concerns
of the whales”, he understands that he’s
talking crap.
He wants the DAO to give him money, the anonymous
whales in question do not want him to receive
money.
There is no negotiating or compromising, just
pharaohs you can pray to.
So that leads us naturally onto the subject
of the DAO’s management.
The DAO has been speed-running bureaucratic
paralysis.
In 2020 they attempted to automate governance
by running an on-chain system, but it didn’t
work, no one wanted to pay transaction costs
to vote on every name ban and point of interest,
so they moved the system back off-chain six
months later.
Problem is that without automation you need
humans to push the buttons.
Decentraland is quite proud of the DAO’s
grant scheme - but it’s been a massive headache
for them recently.
For the first year they gave away 3.5 million
dollars in grants to develop projects that
would aid adoption, but the grant application
had no standard process, and grants had no
oversight and no accountability - because
no one existed with the authority to do it.
The initial proposal alluded to the idea of
revoking grants - but included no framework
to implement it.
So the DAO Committee put forward a proposal
to set up a Squad whose job would be to help
grantees deliver their product - and in the
extreme case where a project had collapsed
or was too far off course, the Squad could
recommend that the Committee revoke the grant.
But the Committee is administrative, they
can’t revoke the grant, and the Squad are
essentially independent contractors, they
can’t revoke the grant either, so we need
a new committee with express permission to
revoke grants.
Enter the Grant Revocation Committee.
We could go crazy with dissecting this, but
the short version is that these committees
are meant to have minimal discretion.
The authors of the policy seem to think discretion
only exists if you acknowledge it.
So rather than limiting the scope of consideration
like any other discretionary position in government,
they limit the committee to only considering
cases that are actively handed to them, but
put no restraints on the committee members’
actual decision making effectively giving
them absolute power to revoke any grant for
any reason.
And as the cherry on top, there’s no appeals
process.
Because to appeal the verdict would require
a different group with the authority to overturn
the decision of the Revocation Committee.
The committee intended to have minimal discretion
is completely unrestrained with zero accountability.
Oh and these guys are paid commission for
every verdict - so the DAO is about to learn
real fast why we don’t do that in the real
world.
Then we have the Facilitation Squad, the Governance
Squad, the Protocol Squad, the Security Advisory
Board, the newly proposed Working Groups.
They’re expanding the DAO Committee from
3 to 5 members, but only after an election
to replace one of the original 3.
In trying to minimize human involvement they
have instead ballooned it, and, like, look
at the participation numbers.
Generously there’s a few hundred people
actively involved in the DAO in any capacity
at all, and at this rate every single one
of them is going to be in at least one squad
or work group.
More realistically the couple dozen people
with the inclination to spend their free time
role playing bureaucrats are going to be sitting
on the accountability squad that has oversight
over the oversight work group that advises
the spending council on how much the accountability
squad should be paid.
Oh, and these bureaucrats are paid in MANA,
which as we’ve seen is a direct source of
political power.
Like, do you remember that time Yemel agreed
with Yemel that Yemel should be paid $150/hour
in MANA?
Would you be shocked to learn that Yemel,
who agreed with Yemel about paying Yemel $150
an hour, is friends with Melich and Ordano
from back in the days when they all spent
their time at a tech bro flop house they called
Casa Voltaire?
And through all this bureaucratic garbage,
it’s easy to lose sight of the truth.
The DAO has no actual authority.
Decentraland isn’t “owned by its users”,
it's owned by its owners - the Foundation.
While the Foundation cedes the copyright on
material submitted by users, the Terms of
Use make it very clear that the Foundation
holds the copyright on the Decentraland part
of Decentraland.
As Catalina Goanta points out, this conflicts
with the rhetoric that Decentraland is owned
by its users, when the most significant legal
right in this area is unambiguously owned
by the Foundation.
Even looking past that, can it really be said
that Decentraland is owned by its users when
the DAO is currently being held hostage by
a dozen whales whose proportional voting rights
dwarf their peers?
Now, being a digital landlord doesn’t require
much engagement at all.
I would hazard that whoever owns fifty identical
Decentraland homes plastered with For Sale
advertisements isn’t really a Decentraland
user above the most literal threshold.
I, on the other hand, am demonstrably a user
of Decentraland.
Given how dead engagement is I feel pretty
confident in estimating that I spend far more
hours per year actively looking around and
doing stuff in the world than the median LAND
owner.
But I am not an owner of Decentraland by virtue
of that time spent in the world, there is
no mechanism that correlates the two, that
gives ownership to those who use it and strips
ownership from those who idly hoard.
The mechanism of ownership is not usage, it’s
ownership of LAND and MANA.
The arc of Decentraland’s development is
dictated by the Foundation.
They may occasionally ask the DAO what features
they’d want to see, or act on simple proposals
for technical changes - but the DAO is not
Decentraland’s board of directors.
“First, Decentraland is always working with
the community because we are a DAO.
As a decentralized platform we are mostly
governed by the DAO.
So we are not a corporation, so our roadmap
also operates differently because we always
try to look into what the community is aiming.”
Notice how she doesn’t say “we’re bound
by the decisions of the DAO, because they’re
our bosses”.
Instead the Foundation is “working with
the community” and “trying to look into
where the community is aiming.”
When discussing Decentraland’s prospective
value to actual businesses, the Foundation
can’t say with a straight face that representatives
from Target need to get in touch with the
DAO Facilitation Squad to outline the contents
of a proposal.
At a certain point, all the talk of decentralized
ownership and political revolution needs to
get put aside so Dolce & Gabbana will actually
respond to the emails.
In Line Goes Up, we all had a good laugh at
DAOs whose central product was undefined.
“Are we a comic book, or a bi-monthly curated
box of snacks?”
But to their credit - that is in keeping with
the philosophy of a DAO.
In the case of Decentraland, the Foundation
came first and knows what it is, and what
it wants to be.
If the DAO were to vote for the project to
become a 2D Metroidvania set in a hypothetical
fourth Punic War, in the visual style of NHL
‘94 - sorry, that isn’t happening.
The Foundation acts autonomously whenever
it wants.
When the Foundation implemented “the first
ATM in the metaverse”, they didn’t consult
the DAO before starting development.
And can you blame them?
Can you imagine if, as a business, they were
bound by the whims of these losers?
Despite the rhetoric, the Foundation isn’t
dependent on the DAO, in truth it's the opposite.
The DAO can’t function without the Foundation.
Not just in the obvious ways, but from top
to bottom.
The 2021 proposal to go off-chain came from
the Executive Director of Decentraland.
In the proposal, he nominated three individuals
to serve as the administrative Committee members
- all of whom were working at the Foundation
at the time.
The Decentraland DAO simply lacks the means
to function autonomously.
Through lack of tools, unimaginable inequality,
general incompetence and a lack of authority,
the DAO is impotent.
So is it any wonder that their grant scheme
can turn $240,000 into the MetaGamiMall?
What else could this system possibly produce?
One of the most telling moments in the Decentraland
timeline is the June 2019 blog post announcing
the switch from the Babylon engine to Unity.
Not because of the engine change in and of
itself but because of this note: jumping
added.
Jumping puzzles, it’s important to note,
are functionally the single ludic interaction
inherent to Decentraland’s mechanics.
The only games that you see in the world with
any consistency, games that actually involve
interacting with the space and not with a
two dimensional UI element, are scavenger
hunts and jumping puzzles.
Unless you’re headed to the gambling halls,
jumping on things is functionally the only
thing to consistently do in Decentraland and
it was, this is important, an afterthought.
2019, that’s four years of development before
jumping was added as basic functionality.
Ari Meilich and Esteban Ordano are Argentinian
developers who met in a “hacker house”
known as Casa Voltaire.
Most of what we know about Casa Voltaire comes
from two online articles, one from 2017 and
another from 2020.
Casa Voltaire hit the sweet spot of anonymity,
there’s not really any contemporary information
about what was going on there because it was
just a flop house for tech bros, but it left
just enough of a footprint to become mythologised.
“the community at the Voltaire Castle became
a worldwide legend a crazy hacker haven for
cryptocurrency projects”
As Ryan Vanzo describes it, the house was
a communal workspace where small start ups
would operate in the house and share resources
and expertise.
This was combined with a heady blend of smartboy
philosophy.
Both of the previously mentioned articles
paint a picture of genius, citing the deep
conversations that would take place within
the group.
But, ya know, here’s the deep, moral dilemmas
Vanzo cites in his story.
How should autonomous cars act in a situation
that would save the driver but kill a pedestrian?
Who is liable if a bot malfunctions and causes
harm?
What kind of neuro-security should we develop
to protect users of brain-to-brain interfaces?
So, like, a high school introduction to ethics.
One of those is literally the trolly problem.
In this environment, and within the context
of Argentina’s political volatility, Ordano
and Meilich conceived of Decentraland as a
bunch of things, principally a fulfillment
of the fantasy of Snow Crash, The Matrix,
and, of course, Ready Player One.
“The idea was basically whether we could
do a virtual world that was based on open
standards and the blockchain and whether we
could encode the physics into... into a blockchain.
Of course influenced by videos and movies
like The Matrix, Ready Player One, and Snow
Crash.”
But inside that was an inkling of the political,
the notion that this could be a test bed for
political movements, for new economies, and,
ideally, liberation movements.
Writing for Rest of the World, Leo Schwartz
and Lucia Cholakian Herrera describe it, skeptically,
as “a petri dish for the ideals of democracy
and decentralization they championed, built
on the premise that a virtual world controlled
by its own “citizens” could more effectively
govern itself — and offer more stable investment
opportunities — than a real one governed
by elites.”
Of course in reality Decentraland is steered
exclusively by its own elites, people who
bought in hard and early and have the voting
power to dismiss any challenge to their power,
or literal project insiders who have the social
capital and access to the code base to simply
end-run the will of the whales.
Because Decentraland is not a petri dish,
sterilized and sealed off from our reality.
In 2003, writers rushed to herald Second Life
as the vanguard of the future, not just a
video game, but a new place that couldn’t
have existed before.
Two years prior, Edward Castronova had argued
that Everquest and virtual worlds like it
were important because the objects in them
were worth money.
In response to Second Life, Castronova predicted
that in the future, humanity would pick the
virtual world over the real.
“The exodus of people from the real world,
from our normal daily life, of living rooms,
cubicles and shopping malls, will create a
change in social climate that makes global
warming look like a tempest in a teacup.”
Philip Rosedale, a developer on Second Life,
went even further.
“The real world will become like a museum
very soon.
So it’ll be fantastically cool to go to
New York, but in the same way that it’s
cool to go see the Mayan ruins.
Because the big buildings will still be there,
but they’ll be covered in dust.
Because no one will bother too much with them
anymore.”
There’s just one tiny, almost inconsequential
problem here, just a little thing, we’ll
talk about it in a moment here, but just maybe
keep in mind that there’s a small little
issue.
Johan Huizinga is known for his landmark anthropologic
work Homo Ludens, published in 1938.
Huizinga was concerned with the interaction
between play and culture.
And a key element of that was trying to define
‘play’.
What is the difference between a fight and
play-fight?
How is it that chalk on grass can produce
a boundary that people take seriously during
a game of soccer?
Huizinga proposed the concept of the “magic
circle”, which aims to describe how play
space is delineated from the ordinary world.
In a game of Dungeons & Dragons, the rules
and instructions alone aren’t enough to
represent the entire game world, it is “the
compound relationship of formal, social, dramatic
and aesthetic elements.”
Essentially, when you buy into the game, everything
comes together to create a kind of pocket
dimension, a psychological bubble, where board
pieces, dice rolls and social interactions
can take on unique meanings distinct from
reality.
In a game of soccer, the players all agree
to obey the rules of the game and a social
contract forms.
Suddenly the ball, chalk, and their own limbs
take on properties prescribed to them in the
player’s mind, boundaries become respectable
and in respecting them they become real.
If, however, someone then karate chops the
opposing goalie in the throat, the bubble
bursts - the contract has been broken, the
circle has been pierced, and the lines on
the ground stop mattering real fast.
In an honest engagement, where the fiction
is unavoidably present but elided for the
sake of immersion we would call the circle
suspension of disbelief or kayfabe.
Tom Boellstroff and Edward Castronova both
sought to push Second Life as a ‘real place,’
separate from the real world, where genuine
research could be done.
Boellstroff argued that Second Life was a
fixed site of culture, like a Pacific Island.
Edward Castronova made a career out of arguing
that Second Life is a site of genuine economic
activity.
They, not in their words but in criticism,
present Second Life as existing within an
impermeable magic circle, as like The Matrix,
somewhere you travel to, a place.
Okay, but there’s just that one, tiny, minuscule
problem, and that’s that people who “live”
in Second Life don’t actually live in Second
Life.
You can eat an infinite amount of digital
food in virtual reality and you will still
starve.
But the metaverse both presumes and requires
that legitimacy of place and the real.
Either the outright reification of Ryan Bolger,
or digital fashion being pushed as genuine
property, it needs to be real in order to
be meaningful.
So the authors of Decentraland, its creators
and its users, paint a magic circle around
it with a narrative of inevitability, a narrative
of the metaverse, a narrative of a true, separate,
new world that you will eventually move your
life into.
Because if your neighbors aren’t going to
eventually be compelled to be here tomorrow,
why would you ever want this today?
Decentraland is, at every level, a collective
fairy tale.
Just people playing pretend.
“The feeling of these shows was that we
all performed a fashion week, rather than
participating in it.”
Whether it be the Pedigree Fosterverse scraping
data from adoptapet, users playing lawyer
in their corporate offices or purporting to
be the future of news - Decentraland’s value
to businesses is plainly absurd.
And as we’ve seen, even its decentralized
premise is a fantasy.
The DAO has no authority and is comically
hapless - content to play politics.
All the while pretending they have a stake
in a billion dollar product.
And it’s not enough to convince themselves,
they need to convince you.
So that is what they do by any means necessary.
They will pander, mislead, outright lie - whatever
it takes for you to buy into their narrative.
Because this only makes sense from inside
the circle.
“What if you could own the virtual world?
Create, develop, and trade without limits.
Make genuine connections, and earn real money.”
Decentraland is a farce and a tragedy, it
is painted into a corner by a combination
of ineptitude and inherently bad ideas, and
it cannot escape its fundamental being.
Whatever other ideals are spit out, whatever
rhetoric about liberation or political experimentation
is employed, the simple fact that it was materially
born as a pre-sale of lots of "land" based
on a fiction of people "moving in" sets off
a chain of decisions and incentives about
design and functionality that bind it, forever,
to being little more than a fantasy real estate
scheme, an endless world of uniquely scarce
dead malls.
I can’t use that right now.
Thank you.
Mighty kind of you.
I can’t use that right now.
[gunshot]
Oh my god, what did you do!?
I can’t use that right now.